is some pretty cool news to tell you
about right here at four o'clock a local
professor is chosen to join
a mission to mars yeah this is quite the
honor unlv geoscientist era audrey
was selected out of more than 119
exactly 119 applicants
and she's just one of 13 people to make
the cut across the country
and she's also the second unlv professor
chosen this is for the mars science team
so audrey will help the rover
distinguish
magnetic rocks which are formed from the
cooling of lava
and determine how these rocks are
actually formed audrey says this has
been a dream of hers
since she was a teenager i'm going to
use a specific instrument so there's
total of seven different science
instruments on the mass rover and i will
use
some of them to understand the geology
of gizero crater which is where the
rover perseverance will land
these rocks will help audrey and her
colleagues understand the evolution of
the martian interior over time
it's pretty neat right you know and she
looks so young and so
beautiful it was like she's like right
out of the movies when you see like the
really smart scientists
right she looks like hilary swank in the
uh the show netflix
show they had uh they went to mars
called away she looks like one you know
right in the cast there
beautiful and smart congratulations to
her yeah we'll have to get some pictures
you know for sure
all right